commissaire européen au marché intérieur
thierry breton a par exemple jugé que
l'union européenne n'avait donc pas
besoin du vaccin russe estimant que les
quatre vaccins autorisés jusque là était
suffisant des déclarations qui ne sont
pas véritablement bien accueillie du
côté de moscou en effet la russie y voit
des tentatives d'empêcher l'utilisation
de sportive et au sein de l'union
européenne
écoutez vaccins disponibles
la situation autour du lac sens unique v
et révéla des listes aucune victime et
que la pandémie que l'unesco en tant que
problème
nous pouvons être résolu que
conjointement puisque comme dans l'axé
un virus comme le crime et le terrorisme
ne connaissent pas de frontières non un
show axonais hausse exigée des approches
véritablement collective
cependant notre d'accès a été confronté
à une campagne de désinformation à des
discriminations mais a été
démonstrativement ignoré par les
institutions européennes
aujourd'hui le bon sens il emporte peu à
peu le vaccin a déjà été enregistrées
par certains pays membres de l'union
européenne la hongrie et la slovaquie où
il était convenu de fabriquer le vaccin
russe en italie l'agencé européenne des
médicaments
il est en train d'examiner pour la
demande concernant l'enregistrement du
vaccin russe que sa commercialisation
néanmoins nous continuons de constater
des tentatives d'empêcher l'utilisation
de spoutnik vais le territoire de
l'union européenne
on note des déclarations politiques
qu'on ne peut que qualifier de
profondément politisé et qui ne vise pas
à vaincre ce fléau et à relever ce défi
tous ensemble ces remarques
interviennent dans un contexte bien
particulier celui d'une pénurie de
vaccins encore amplifié par l'annoncent
d'importants retards de livraison du
vaccin d'astrazeneca on entend dans
certains pays européens comme la hongrie
n'ont pas attendu la validation du
régulateur européen des médicaments pour
se fournir en spoutnik v auprès de la
russe d'autres pays comme l'italie
pourrait également faire preuve de
pragmatisme et agir par eux mêmes et ce
dans les toutes prochaines semaines